Britney Spears the big question that
we've all been asking how is her mental
health well this is the clearest glimpse
that we've gotten yet Britney kept
things upbeat during a weekend of outlet
store shopping with her boyfriend of two
years sam muscari it was kind of a
silent statement to the world that she's
doing okay just listen to her reaction
to this paparazzo CT has learned
Britney's conservatorship is business as
usual she talks to dad Jamie several
times a day our source also says there
is no need to hashtag free Britney
because she already has the freedom to
go where she wants however Britney must
have a security escort and she can't go
places like liquor stores on Friday
Britney rocked the crop top and low-rise
jeans for their day David the 37 year
old former Mickey Mouse Club member hit
the disney store before the chivalrous
25 year old personal trainer escorted
her back to her car our 80 source says
quote Sam has truly been there for
Britney and is supporting her throughout
her latest struggle with bipolar
disorder good man standing by her our
source says that medication is still key
for Britney at this point and quote
functioning without medication isn't an
option for her well you may wonder about
Britney's two sons during all of this
Britney's ex coming Federline has
custody but they do often visit with
Britney
[Music]